la fiscalía y la policía allanaron la
casa del ex Primer Ministro Daniel
Torres con la finalidad de encontrar
información que refuerce la
investigación que realiza el Ministerio
Público por los delitos de rebelión y
conspiración durante el fallido golpe de
estado del expresidente Pedro Castillo
el pasado 7 de diciembre más de una
decena de policías de la división de
alta tecnología cumpliendo una orden
judicial registran la vivienda del ex
hombre de confianza de Pedro Castillo
para hallar documentos y cualquier tipo
de prueba que permite esclarecer los
hechos y la participación de Aníbal
Torres en la organización elaboración
del mensaje presidencial y la frustrada
fuga de Pedro Castillo a la embajada de
México en Lima para solicitar un asilo
político la orden judicial que tiene un
plazo de 48 horas contiene una
autorización para incautar bienes
computadoras celulares equipos
electrónicos entre otros a nivel Torres
cumple un impedimento de salida del país
por 18 meses que le fue impuesta por la
sala penal permanente de la Corte
Suprema en diciembre de 2022 algunos
analistas señalan que este es un duro
golpe para el entorno del expresidente
Pedro Castillo porque hace unas horas El
Congreso de Perú aprobó acusar
constitucionalmente a la ex primer
ministra Betsy Chávez por delitos de
rebelión y conspiración al supuestamente
organizar el mensaje donde Pedro
Castillo ordenaba el cierre del
parlamento